hyperthermic intraperitoneal
chemotherapy or HIPEC is a treatment
option for patients with advanced
cancers that have spread to the
abdominal cavity or peritoneum
doctors begin with what is called
cytoreductive surgery to remove all
visible tumors in the abdominal area
the extent of the surgery depends on the
findings during surgery surgery can
involve the removal of tumors in the
upper and lower abdominal area on the
omentum
on the liver
stomach
small intestine
:
rectum
[Music]
pancreas
spleen
appendix
uterus
ovaries
and the peritoneal surfaces
surgery to remove tumors is thorough and
aggressive with the goal of preserving
organs whenever possible
the doctor carefully examines the
abdominal region quadrant by quadrant
searching for and removing tumors
with great care the doctor uses highly
specialized surgical techniques to strip
the tumors from the peritoneal surfaces
and organs and seal small blood vessels
of the visible tumors are removed
next the doctor administers the HIPEC or
heated chemotherapy treatment with a
goal of killing any remaining cancer
cells that cannot be seen tubes and
temperature probes are placed into the
abdominal cavity
the doctor briefly closes the skin of
the abdomen with sutures
the abdominal cavity is flooded with a
solution that includes chemotherapy
drugs this solution is heated
the tubes and probes are connected to a
machine this controls the temperature
and flow of the solution
the heated chemotherapy solution is
continuously circulated throughout the
abdominal cavity so that the cavity is
uniformly exposed to heat and
chemotherapy
the combination of heat and chemotherapy
causes the solution to kill microscopic
cancer cells
gentle shaking is applied to the abdomen
to help the solution distribute to all
surfaces within the abdomen
following the HIPEC treatment the fluid
is drained from the abdominal cavity
the abdomen is reopened and the tubes
and probes are removed
at this time any necessary
reconstructive surgery is performed for
example the doctor may need to reconnect
a resected colon
finally the doctor closes the abdominal
incision the surgery and HIPEC treatment
together may take six to 12 hours to
complete